hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara Jessa and today I
went and saw wreck-it Ralph - Ralph
breaks the internet I think I think
that's the title there's a lot of words
there Ralph breaks the internet for
words are we kidding
I guess I mostly is so unsure about the
name of this film because I didn't see
the first one yes that's right come one
come all
mock the girl who never saw wreck-it
Ralph that was critically acclaimed and
was so good apparently and I still
haven't seen it what did I watch this
week for Tamara's never seen that I
actually just watched this instead what
was it oh yeah I forgot I went into this
film skeptical because I don't enjoy
movies that bring in the Internet to its
story I was talking with a lot of
friends over the last few weeks about
this actually I was on a film set and we
were speaking a lot about kind of things
that we don't enjoy film trope so we
don't enjoy and that is like my big one
then I just I think it dates it
immediately as if you're talking about
not that emoji movie was ever gonna be
anything other than garbage but emoji
movie completely gave dit itself
immediately when it's like oh we're on
Twitter now and oh we're on snapchat now
and it's like these things that like who
knows in two years it might be gone I
just even seeing it now when it's those
things are thriving it still feels so
dated somehow to me I always hate it
when it's done in horror I think it's
usually not done well with the exception
of probably only black mirror I just
it's not my cup of tea so I went into
this being like well this is a sequel
where I haven't seen the first my fault
but also where they incorporate breaking
the internet into the title so I wasn't
completely on board was not completely
looking forward to this and I think I
cried like six times because it was so
good it's that time of year right where
it's that sweet spot in between
Halloween and New Year where you just
want to take a really lovely lovely
content
and you want to cry and get the feels as
the kids say I cannot recommend this
movie enough I still stand by what I
said earlier that I don't love the
internet aspect I think they did the
best take on it I've seen other again
other than black mirror also I really
desperately want to cosplay now as
vanellope such a cool character
especially in the all princess scenes
where they're all like these beautiful
damsels in distress not really that's
another thing I'll get to but she's
surrounded by all these beautiful ball
gown princesses and she's singing about
slaughterhouse the game or slot or
something the game and I just loved her
she's weirdo and kind of an outcast and
I love it I'm all about that
I would love to cosplay as her give me a
wig with some sprinkles on it and we're
in business
my first three notes are rap dude didn't
see it don't like internet movies but I
cried at How to Train Your Dragon hidden
world trailer so yeah good lord
also am I the only one who thinks Dumbo
looks and then I drew flames for fire
like like lit like good but it looks
like a crown because I can't draw
anything moving on okay one thing the
movie starts off and the producer the
writer and the director are all sitting
there in chairs then they're like thanks
for coming to our movie and this takes
so many people are on our team why don't
I always find that super weird they did
that for Incredibles too I didn't mind
it as much in Incredibles too because it
was like oh we've been taking a long
time for this so here's the voice cast
like here's the cast of it like saying
thanks for waiting thanks for loving us
this was like three people that we don't
know at all I don't know it felt it felt
weird it's not my favorite because they
were like attempting some comedy it
wasn't even terrible comedy it's just
it's just like a little out of place I
guess it's just it's change it's
something that I've not seen very much
of before and I don't love it basically
the gist of the film is that the game
that vanellope is in in the arcade that
they live in has broken and instead of
getting it fixed they're just gonna
scrap the game so she is going to die
essentially
not have a home because it's kind of her
and Ralph's fault that this happens
ralph decides they're going to go into
the internet which is a new thing for
their arcade the Wi-Fi or the whiffy as
they call it and they're going to go to
ebay or a boy as he calls it and they're
going to bid on the controls that they
need to fix the game so they do that
they've been way too much because they
don't realize they're bidding with money
they think they're just trying to outdo
the number before them it's really cute
and then it's a race to find like
something like $27,000 to buy this
controller for her racing game so to do
that they have to go into the Internet
and there is a lot of things happening
here there's snapchat Fandango Google
eBay IMDB Amazon YouTube Twitter
Facebook another thing that's not
YouTube but it's like the competitor of
YouTube in this world specifically I
feel like this is the most traffic that
eBay has had in years honestly I used to
love eBay I've not been on in a long
time like I said that kind of makes it
feel dated to me to be like oh my god
this like whole thing like it's kind of
surrounded by eBay it's weird especially
because I feel like the kids that
they're marketing to especially don't
know what eBay is or they know what it
is they haven't personally been on it
before and there's a lot of like eBay
inside jokes so I just seemed that was a
little it's a little out of place but
again they did it in such a good way
there were not many moments where I felt
like oh my gosh you're really pushing
this brand on me versus like you're
using it to tell this story which is
like the opposite of what the emoji
movie did this just made me think of the
emoji movie a lot because they're very
similar things there in the internet it
was nice that this was done in a good
way and in a beautiful way that made me
cry like 60 it's also Miranda sings is
in this movie I was like so many
references in my notes there's like a
lot of things being referenced and so if
any misstep had happened with the
writing or the directing or the
the animation it would have really been
cheesy but thankfully it was great
a lot of things lead up to this but
Ralph eventually goes viral with a video
and he finds out that he can make money
by making viral videos so he makes a ton
of videos a ton of things that I watch
regularly on YouTube but it was on this
other partner site not YouTube is like
their competitor so not the partner site
he has to get enough hearts to make
enough money he has to make $27,000 in
like eight hours which is a hilarious
thought for someone if he's like on
YouTube trying to make some money at it
for sure
and I'm knowing like how much you make
that's a long fuse Ralph that's a lot of
use you got to get there buddy
it also it comes like 30 days later this
alternate site it's like transfer funds
now okay well it's a good thing they
didn't put it on YouTube then because
that would have been extremely
unrealistic I wrote it's so well done
but it's weird it's just weird to see
this movie take place on the internet I
think I know the internet has been
around long enough for us to talk about
it in film it just it feels a little
weird you know what I mean it's not just
me I don't know movies are so easily
ruined by the internet I feel like it
was really really well done but I still
just have that in the back of my brain
just being like oh my god this is about
the Internet then you get into the
Disney area and that was what amazing
there was Marvel characters there were
stormtroopers following her there was a
just incredible cameo that I don't want
to give away but just it made me smile
made me cry re crying I really loved the
Disney Princess part it's not the
contrast the vanilla P had with the
other princesses was really great and I
thought they were all captured really
great also the princess has come back at
the end and one of the lines is so funny
one of the princesses yells out oh my
gosh a big helpless man to save and they
run out and save him because the whole
thing was that like you know everyone
thinks that they're saved by big men was
cute it was really cute it was subtle it
wasn't like pushing it down your throat
it's really well done
I wrote Oh No Ralph goes into the
that section then I cried it was really
well handled it wasn't a huge part at
the movie I think it would have been
really cheesy if it was a giant thing
making you super insecure to go into the
comment section it was just like it was
just touched upon in a nice enough way
it was like really sweet I felt terrible
for him be nice
so the breaking of the internet happens
like the title spells us it will and
there's some conflicts in their
relationship as friends and it's all
resolved in such a nice way in such a
way that's like okay I did this really
bad thing and I am so truly sorry for it
it wasn't just like pushed over I just
watched son of the mask and every
conflict was fixed by the lead character
Tim Avery being like I'm sorry and I'm
the worst and then everyone was like
yeah cool hero it's all fine this was
like true true true apologies
truly incredible writing I loved this
movie for you so well done
heartwarming honest funny cute ten out
of ten thank you so much for watching if
there's ever any movies that you
desperately want me to see for Tamra
just saw I'm always like going in
between one or two that are coming out
that week and so it's always really nice
to hear from people like on Twitter if
there's one that you specifically want
to see let me know there Tamra L
chambers and I will see you guys next
week bye
[Music]